when a water lily beetle sees food on a  pond surface it doesn't swim or soar it  water skis anchored to the water surface  with its claws it lifts up its head and  starts flapping reaching speeds of up to  half a meter per second the beetles legs  are hairy and waterproof but its claws  are hair free allowing them to stick  under the water surface thanks to the  waters rippling resistance traveling  this way takes even more work than  flying through the air so why do it  researchers say it's easier for the  beetle to find its favorite pond plants  in two dimensions rather than in three  so not getting lost might outweigh the  energy cost of skimming the surface  you